a suicide squad is unlike any other film
in the dc eu
it's gorier it's more chaotic and it's
hysterical
there's also a lot that happens at the
end while the movie has a clear
resolution there are some nuances worth
examining in further detail
let's dive in with an obvious spoiler
warning
after the suicide squad finally makes
their way to jotunheim they split up
into two groups
one to track down the villainous
starfish-like being known as starro and
another to plant explosives
brick flag leads the group bringing the
thinker to staro where they find out
several awful truths
first staro spits out many starfish
which latch onto hosts murder them and
become an extension of staro
second staro came from outer space a
fact known to the audience but not to
most of the characters
third and most damningly star was being
researched on and kept in corto maltese
said to be hess to the united states
government for maximum deniability
meanwhile the bomb planting squad
partially led by bloodsport starts
working their way up the tower and
setting up explosives
a few crucial miscommunications result
in a bomb being destroyed early which
sets off a chain detonation and slowly
levels the building
it's right around this time that flag
grabs a hard drive and declares he's
going to reveal the truth to the
american press
only to find out that peacemaker had
secret orders from amanda waller to make
sure that info never saw the light of
day
everyone on the lower level gets knocked
out by the blast and a struggle ensues
between flag and peacemaker over the
hard drive
one which ends in flag's death
peacemaker tries to kill ratcatcher 2
but bloodsport manages to survive the
explosion and shoots peacemaker first
staro now free and having killed the
thinker starts wreaking havoc from the
nearby city with the hostile government
destabilized waller declares the mission
complete
but bloodsport polkadot man ratcatcher 2
king shark and harley decide that
they're not
done until starro is defeated waller
comes inches from detonating the bombs
in their necks but is knocked out by her
own employees
bloodsport takes charge and organizes a
plan of attack
after a grueling battle in which each
member uses their own special abilities
starro is defeated alas polka dot man
dies during the battle
we're all gonna die i hope so
at this time the courtois maltese
freedom fighters topple the military
leadership and plan to establish a new
democratic government
by this point the squad's exploits and
the death of starro are worldwide news
and seen by bloodsport's daughter half a
world away
bloodsport who held onto the drive
uploads it to a secure server giving
waller a choice
their immediate freedom or he'll release
the info waller acknowledges that
bloodsport did indeed become a leader
and accepts his terms
even though america's involvement will
be kept secret the squad gets their
freedom and saves a sovereign nation
mid and post credit scenes reveal that
weasel survived the beach assault and
that peacemaker barely survived and that
there's a mission ready for him
now that we've recapped the ending let's
break down some of the themes and how
the movie set them up we'll start by
acknowledging what waller promised at
the start that she'd make bloodsport a
leader bloodsport spends a film showing
bits and pieces of leadership
he and flag also do most of the planning
for their abortive rescue of harley
quinn
bloodsport also acts as the de facto
leader of the group at the top of the
tower
taking point on the operation by the
time starro is up and kicking rick flag
is dead and peacemaker has betrayed the
group
and is also seemingly dead himself this
is also the moment bloodsport becomes a
leader and it happens so organically
that he doesn't even notice
he's the first member to ignore waller's
orders and the one who gives
instructions on how they should fight
starro
if bloodsport is the heart of task force
x ratcatcher 2
is the soul while summoning the rad army
she remembers her late father
in one of the most tear-jerking moments
of the whole film ratcatcher tells his
daughter why he loves rats
because if these vile creatures can find
a place for themselves in the world
anyone can the surviving members of task
force x are
largely morally decent or at least
morally neutral people driven to crime
by circumstance
bloodsport is a mercenary king shark is
a creature of pure id too stupid to be
good or evil
polkadot man was the victim of an
experiment and ratcatcher 2 was left
alone after her father tragically died
and all she had were rats indeed
ratcatcher 2's rats identified
bloodsport as a good person early on and
she reminds bloodsport of that later
more than anything however they're
misfits none of them quite gelled with
the outside world with bloodsport who is
still a neglectful father the closest to
normal
king shark never had a friend before
ratcatcher 2 offered to become his
polka dot man is a tragic lonely figure
whose shyness is compounded by a deeply
embarrassing power
harley has thrice been unlucky in love
and has struggled to find her place
after breaking up with joker
it's unknown what each will do with
their newfound freedom but like rats
these vile creatures have found a place
for themselves in the world
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one